uh the PM being weak I think he's just
getting an opportunity yes addition to
my duties in this house I shall have
further such meetings later today John
Hodge thank you Mr Speaker does prime
minister agree with his friend the
cheese Valley mayor that the National
Audit office must investigate the tease
Works
um affair and Willie share details of
all conversations he has had on the
subject with his former Chief secretary
the member from Middlesbrough South and
the current leveling up Minister given
that they've all received donations from
Ian Waller one of the project backers
well Mr Mr Speaker honorable friend uh
leveling up secretary has already
announced uh owning an investigation
into this matter but what I would say
it's just the same old same old
all we get all we get after years of
neglect it's the conservatives that are
delivering for tea side
Mr Speaker everyone here has NHS trusts
in our constituencies grappling with
backlogs so can I highlight the
commitment and hard work of the
gloucestershire hospital's trust in
bringing down the waiting list over 18
months ahead of the government deadline
and fast reducing the over 65-weight
waiting list does my right honorable
friend agree with me that those who
imagined that the opposition has a magic
wand up their sleeve to solve these
problems need look no further than the
woes of the Betsy could wallowed aboard
in North Wales under labor political
control for a Generation
Well Mr Speaker as my honorable friend
says gloucestershire in particular has
seen a significant reduction in a e
waiting times since December we
recognize of course though there is more
to be done and that's why we're
delivering on our plan to recover urgent
and emergency care to ensure that people
get the care they need easier faster and
closer to home
stama
how many work visas were issued to
foreign Nationals last year
this week the most the the most recent
the most recent statistics we have the
most recent history we had as the owner
said at the time contained a set of
unique circumstances including welcoming
many people here for humanitarian
reasons
the figures are out it's a quarter of a
million work visas were issued last year
he knows that answer he just doesn't
want to give it and the new numbers
tomorrow are expected to be even higher
the Prime Minister stood on three Tory
manifestos each one promised to reduce
immigration each promise broken they all
stood on those manifestos as well
why does he think his Home Secretary
I've got aware of this question those
who don't want to hear it we know the
answer here's Dharma they all they all
stood on those manifestos so why does he
think his Home Secretary seems to have
such a problem coping with points-based
systems
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
and the same respect will be sure the
Prime Minister well Mr Speaker just this
week we announced the biggest ever
single measure to tackle legal migration
removing the right for international
students to bring dependents toughening
the rules on post-study work and
reviewing maintenance requirements but
what is the honorable gentleman's
contribution there are absolutely no
ideas
no no
no absolutely no I did absolutely no
semblance that there would be any
control why because he believes in an
Open Door migration policy
to see what uncontrolled immigration
looks like all they've got to do is wake
up tomorrow morning listen to the
headlines and see what this government
Miss Bristol I think you're going to be
leaving
I'm asking you to leave no because
otherwise I'll name it
but having it and I've warned you before
it's the same people
[Applause]
on this side
okay some Mr Speaker the reason they're
issuing so many visas is labor and
skills shortages and the reasons there
are shortages is the low-wage Tory
economy under his government rules
businesses in I.T engineering Healthcare
architecture welding can pay foreign
workers 20 less than British workers for
years and years on end does he think his
policy is encouraging businesses to
train people here or hire from abroad
prime minister Mr Speaker he talks about
immigration but we know his position
because it turns out that labor would
actually like to see even more people
coming to the UK increasing the numbers
that's not just my view Mr Speaker those
were the words of his own from bencher
who said having a Target isn't sensible
and that the numbers might have to go up
Mr Speaker so it's clear whilst we're
getting on with clamping down on legal
migration listening to the British
public he's quote perfectly comfortable
wanting to say that he wants free
movement back
[Music]
Mr Speaker they've lost control of the
economy they've lost control of public
services and now they've lost control of
immigration and if he was serious about
weaning his government off the
immigration lever he would get serious
about wages in Britain and get serious
about skills and training the
apprenticeship Levy isn't working it's
hard to find a single business that
thinks that it is and the proof is that
almost half the levy isn't even being
spent that's fewer young people getting
the opportunities they need to fulfill
their potential businesses are trying
out for more flexibility in the levy so
they could train up their staff labor
would give them that why won't he
Mr Speaker it's it's right that we're
talking about education and skills what
he failed to mention
Ed in the past week what did we discover
thanks to the reforms of the
conservative government our young people
are now the best readers in the western
world
proposed by the party opposite he also
he also talked about our record on the
economy and I am very surprised Mr
Speaker because I've stood here week
after week when he's been so Keen to
quote the IMF Mr Speaker now
and he he seemed he seemed to have
missed their press conference yesterday
where they actually said they actually
raised our growth forecast by one of the
highest they've ever done said that
we've acted decisively to make sure that
the economy is growing and credited this
government with having a very positive
effect on future growth
[Applause]
is the prime minister seriously
suggesting that breaking the economy
breaking Public Services losing control
of immigration is some sort of killed
Fair carefully crafted plan his policies
are holding working people back and all
the offers is more of the same but fear
not because speeding into the void left
by the Prime Minister comes the Home
Secretary
not with a plan for skills growth or
wages no her big idea is for British
workers to become fruit Pickers just in
case I can hardly believe she said this
that they forget how to do things
does the Prime Minister support this let
them pick fruit ambition for Britain or
does he wish he had the strength to give
her a career change of her own
Mr Speaker he talked he talks he talks
about public service he talks about the
economy again I think he's just failed
to know what notice what's going on the
IMF as they've said the IMs of they said
it's right here Mr Speaker our forecast
which he was very keen to point out just
a few months ago now their forecasts are
that we will have stronger growth than
Germany France and Italy Mr Speaker what
do they say they're saying that we are
prioritizing what's right for the
British people Mr Speaker he talked
about public services I said best
reading results in the Western World
when it comes to the NHS what have we
just discover last week ambulance
waiting times at the fastest response in
two years Mr Speaker that's a
conservative government delivering for
the British people
Mr Speaker the Home Secretary may need a
speed awareness course he needs a
reality change
smash on immigration reveals a Tory
party with no ambition for working
people and
New Britain just the same old failed
ideas low wages and high tax labor would
fix the apprenticeship Levy fill the
skills Gap and stop businesses from
recruiting from abroad if they don't pay
properly that's because we're the party
of working people what is it say about
him and his party that they won't do the
same
Mr Speaker he
of these names Mr Speaker and look
that's the difference between us Mr
Speaker because every week we we hear we
hear a lot of empty rhetoric from The
Honorable gentleman opposite but in the
past we can measure ourselves by actions
what have we done on this side of the
house we've introduced new powers to
curb disruptive protests we're
protecting public services against on
he's voted against every single one of
those and that's the difference between
us while he's working on the politics
we're working for the British people
you Mr Speaker we have all witnessed how
Putin is carrying out his Savage war
against Ukraine he commenced it he is
the aggressor and he cannot be allowed
to win
that war is now at a pivotal point so
will the Prime Minister use his
friendship with president zielinski to
ensure whatever military equipment they
need they will get be that missiles
drones or jets
oh Mr Speaker it was an honor to welcome
my firm president zielinski to the UK
last week I think everyone will be
collectively proud of the UK's leading
role at the Forefront of supporting
Ukraine we were the first country to
provide support for Ukrainian troops
first country to provide lethal weapons
in Europe at the first to commit named
battle tanks and most recently the first
to provide long-range weapons he will
have seen the powerful scenes coming out
of the G7 Summit in Hiroshima last week
and I've always been clear that we will
stand with Ukraine for as long as it
takes leader of the SMP Stephen Flynn
yeah thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker we
learned today that the price of milk
cheese and eggs are up 29 the place of
pasta it's up 27 the price of a loaf of
bread 18
does the Prime Minister agree that this
is no longer just a cost of living
crisis this is a cost of greed cases
well Mr Speaker is welcome that
inflation has fallen today but as a
Chancellor said we should not be
complacent because there is more work to
do The Honorable gentleman's right to
highlight the impact of food inflation
which is too high at common here in
levels that we've seen in other European
countries like Sweden and Germany we are
providing significant support to help
people with the cost of living and the
chancellor has met with companies in the
supermarket and food supply chain to
make sure that they are doing everything
they can to bring prices down Stephen
Flynn speaker let's get real because the
food inflation remains at near 45 year
high now yesterday the treasury
indicated that the chancellor stands
ready to act but his actions seem to be
predicated on the outcome of our review
by the consumer in Market authorities so
can the Prime Minister perhaps Enlighten
us when does he expect that review to
conclude because Working Families can't
afford to wait much longer yeah well Mr
Speaker on a gentleman will know the CMA
is independent of government but the
chancellor did meet with them recently
to discuss the situation in the grocery
industry and it'll be for the CMA to
make decisions on that but we're doing
everything we can to help consumers
manage the challenges of the cost of
living Mr Speaker but if the SMP wanted
to do their bit maybe that they could
reconsider their deposit return scheme
which has been it's very clear what
people have said it will it will as
people have said it will reduce it will
reduce choice and increase prices for
consumers
to move
the primary care access plan published
this month is a very welcome and
substantive one and my constituents want
to see rapid delivery of it so how
quickly will the government start
providing the 645 million pounds to
Pharmacists and how quickly will the SAS
doctors come to GP surgeries to make
prompt access to Primary Care a reality
for my constituents
prime minister well Mr Speaker I thank
my honorable friend for his contribution
to our primary care plan uh he and I
both know that pharmacies already worked
to help many people with their health
needs and to help delivering our
priority to cut NHS waiting lists they
will be put front and center of our
Primary Care recovery with 645 million
pounds of additional funding that will
be released later this year as
pharmacies start to provide more oral
contraception more blood pressure checks
and crucially for seven common ailments
like ear infections or throat infections
pharmacists will now be able to provide
you with the medicines that you need
follow me thank you Mr Speaker one
quarter of the population of Northern
Ireland are in a health waiting list Our
Workers are on strike for fair pay and
our public finances are in a mess will
he give a commitment that the treasury
will immediately Begin work on a public
sector rescue package so we can
transform the Health Service and ensure
that our public sector workers are given
a decent wage and will he join with the
people of Northern Ireland Mr Speaker
and telling the dup to get back to work
oh Mr Speaker as I've been clear I
firmly believe that Northern Ireland is
governed best when governed locally and
I agree wholeheartedly with him that the
major challenges he raises can only be
properly addressed by the restoration of
the institutions but I also understand
the immediate and pressing concerns he
raises and that's why we've prioritized
Health in the Northern Ireland budget
for this year with 20 million pounds of
more funding and I know my honorable
friend will be an important contributor
to the conversations that the secretary
of state is having to embark on public
service reform and restore the executive
at what Hugh Mr Speaker two weeks ago I
raised the issue of AI with the Prime
Minister only since then we've seen
announcements from firms such as BT that
tens of thousands of jobs are likely to
be lost to this new technology but many
will be created too does the Prime
Minister agree with me that we need to
map the jobs and the regions that will
be most affected by article and issue
intelligence so that we can Target the
skills to prepare britons for the jobs
of the future best
well I think my honorable friend makes
an excellent point and like him I
believe that AI does have the potential
to transform our economy and Society but
of course it has to be introduced safely
and securely we are investing more in AI
skills not only in top tier talent and
but also enabling those from non-stem
backgrounds to access the opportunities
of AI I look forward to getting more
recommendations from him for how we can
strengthen our investment and skills to
make sure everyone can realize the
benefits that this may bring
thank you
while the Prime Minister upgrades his
local energy grid to heat his 40-foot
swimming pool hands oil and gas
companies the likes of BP and shell 11.4
billion in tax breaks he scraps the
energy price guarantee scheme plunging
record numbers of people into poverty is
it just
just coincidence that these same energy
Giants funded the prime minister's
leadership campaign or is he simply out
of touch
Mr Speaker what what we are doing is
taxing the windfall profits of energy
companies and using that money to help
pay around half of a typical household's
energy bill that support is worth 1500
pounds it was extended in the budget by
my right honorable friend the chancellor
and we all look forward to energy bills
coming down which hopefully will be
happening very soon Kevin Foster thank
you uh Mr Speaker he will recall the
commitment he gave to the building a
brighter future plan for major
investment at Torbay Hospital back in
January does this commitment remain
unchanged
well I congratulate my honorable friend
on his continued campaign to improve
tour Bay Hospital I'm delighted to
reconfirm the government's commitment to
Major new facilities there as part of
our new hospitals program and I look
forward to further work progressing in
the months ahead Sarah Olney thank you
very much Mr Speaker under the
conservatives so much of the UK
potential is going untapped anemic
growth falling living standards and
declining International competitiveness
just this morning a solar power company
developing an innovation from Oxford
University said that the UK is the least
attractive Market in which to base its
business due to a lack of incentives
this is a home-grown company that could
have provided well-paid green jobs lost
to this country thanks to the
government's lack of an industrial
strategy so why does the Prime Minister
think it is that each week more and more
promising businesses are choosing to
leave the UK
Mr Speaker the uh The Honorable Library
obviously missed the comments from the
IMF yesterday upgrading our growth
performance she obviously she obviously
missed the survey of thousands of global
CEOs just recently placing the UK as
their number one European investment
destination and and it sounds like she
also missed my trip to Japan last week
where we announced 18 billion pounds of
new investment into the UK economy
Anthony Brown thank you Mr Speaker
liberal democrat-run South Cambridge
District Council is the first in the
country to put its staff on a four day
week without any reduction in pay this
led to a reduction in services and an
increase in costs and yet last week the
liberal Democrats decided to increase
the trial to a year why because the
staff were happier and now unions are
pushing to spread the four-day working
week across the public sector something
that the taxpayers alliance estimates
will cost 30 billion pounds does my
right honorable friend agree with the
Prime Minister agree with me that the
public sector are here to serve the
public and that the liberal Democrats
aren't working
[Applause]
oh
uh Mr Speaker public servants should
rightly focus on delivering for the
public and taxpayers and it is
disappointing to hear from my honorable
friend that his local liberal Democrat
council is not doing this reducing as I
heard staff contact hours and costing
residents more I urge the council to
reconsider their decision because his
residence and constituents in South
Cambridgeshire District Council clearly
deserves better
thank you Mr Speaker in the mission we
are gearing up to Mark the 75th
anniversary of HMT Empire Windrush
arriving in the UK and our Deputy Mayor
Brenda dakers is coordinating our local
events and is herself a daughter of
Windrush generation parents now sadly at
the same time she is organizing advice
surgeries for families who have been
denied their rights and are still
waiting for support from the Windrush
compensate compensation scheme four
years after it opened so with this
Landmark anniversary coming next month
will the Prime Minister commit to ensure
everyone finally gets the compensation
they deserve
okay
well um Mr Mr Speaker I pay tribute to
uh The Honorable ladies considering for
all the work they're doing locally uh
the home office and the government is
delivering on the vast majority of the
recommendations from Wendy Williams
report into this situation and we've
already paid out or offered I believe
over 70 million pounds in compensation
and there are hundreds of Engagement
events happening to ensure that people
are aware of what they're able to access
and will continue to do that engagement
as we promised Linda plotsman thank you
Mr Speaker facet law has benefited from
the multi-billion pound step Fusion
project 20 million in leveling up money
for worksop town center and will now be
part of one of the 20 areas selected as
part of a new 400 million pounds
leveling up partnership but my
constituents in retford feel neglected
by the labor District Council which has
yet to apply for any funds for the town
and is more concerned with trying to
play the two towns off against each
other
could the Prime Minister confirm that
there is no reason whatsoever why
retford cannot benefit from this latest
investment and would he accepts an
invitation to visit Bassett Law to see
the great impact government investment
is already having in the area
well I uh I thank my honorable friend
for his kind invitation to visit and I
shall certainly ask my office to keep it
in mind but as he said as he said
leveling up
[Applause]
as he said leveling up Partnerships are
a commitment to work hand in hand with
20 different places across England most
in need of leveling up and to make sure
that they can realize their potential
and Ambitions as he says they're backed
by 400 million pounds of investment will
make sure that they can be supported to
thrive and I know my writable friend the
leveling up secretary is looking forward
to working with colleagues in Basset law
to identify the best place to focus
their work which could of course include
retford
thank you Mr Speaker
prime minister
for brexit because it would stop
unelected officials in Brussels having
more of a say than his constituents
in 2023 he's asking his MPS to block
Amendment 42 to the EU law Bill to give
unelected officials in Downing Street
more so the laws than this chamber given
the worries and the warnings from his
colleagues why is he going to let the
blob have more say over things like
holiday entitlements than the people who
were elected to do so
Mr Speaker that's just simply not the
case it's the uh it's the elective
government that will be making decisions
about what the right regulations are for
our country and it's absolutely right
that as a result of brexit we can now do
that which is why we are repealing and
reforming over 2 000 pieces of retained
EU law making sure that our statute book
reflects the type of rules and
regulations that are right for the
British economy and will deliver growth
and cut costs for consumers and that's
what our reforms do a little bit more
thank you Mr Speaker a key issue which
has haunted Keithley for many decades is
child sexual exploitation and grooming
gangs I want to see a full Rotherham
style review into child sexual
exploitation across my area but yet
Bradford council's leader and our West
Yorkshire mayor both refused to back one
due to political correctness getting in
the way simply sweeping this issue under
the carpet so will the Prime Minister
for the sake of victims work with me to
ensure that our local leaders do the
morally right thing and instigate a full
Rotherham style inquiry across the
Bradford District
well Mr Speaker can I thank my honorable
friend for campaigning on this so as I
said before we shouldn't let political
correctness stand in the way of keeping
vulnerable girls safe or indeed holding
people to account as he knows it's four
authorities in the local area to
commission local inquiries and I have no
doubt that he will continue to encourage
and them to do so for the government's
part we've commissioned the relevant
inspectorate to examine current policing
practice in response to group-based
sexual exploitation of children and the
home office will not hesitate to act on
its recommendations when they are
published this summer Indie Chamberlain
thank you Mr Speaker and before I was
elected I worked for a number of years
in Learning and Development in both the
police and the private sector and I'm
sure we can all agree that training is
absolutely vital to encourage Innovation
creativity but also for compliance given
that seems to be a particular issue for
the prime minister's cabinet at present
will he agree to support my ministerial
training standards bill that I'll be
presenting later today
yeah
Mr Mr Speaker it's Mr Speaker as a
honorable lady knows there are processes
and procedures in place for ensuring
Professional Standards across government
with regard training what I am pleased
we're doing is rolling out the lifelong
learning entitlement Mr Speaker to
ensure that people at any stage in their
career can get access to years of
government subsidized financing to
ensure that we have a Workforce that's
fit to the Future and everyone can
realize the opportunities that are there
Brian thank you Mr Speaker Owen Carey
died just across the river from here
underneath the London Eye after
suffering a severe allergic reaction
while out celebrating his 18th birthday
he'd simply eaten a chicken burger at a
restaurant which unbeknown to him and
despite his asking have been marinated
in buttermilk Owen's sister Emma who is
my constituent was in Parliament last
week with her dad and her brother for a
debate on food labeling and support for
people with allergies they're fighting
for Owen's law which is campaigning
among other things to change the food
information regulations surrounding
allergy labeling in restaurants
it's attracted huge support so will the
Prime Minister meet with me and Owen's
family to see how we can be sure
something positive comes out of this
tragic loss of a young life
Mr Speaker I thank my honorable friend
for raising Owen's case and I know the
whole house will want to join me in
expressing our condolences to Emma and
all of his family over what happened I
will absolutely ensure that my honorable
friend gets a meeting with the relevant
minister to discuss food labeling
appropriately so that we can make sure
that things like this don't happen Ian
Paisley thank you very much Mr Speaker
will the Prime Minister instruct his
officials to publish the list of 1700
Veterinary medicines that will no longer
be made available to Northern Ireland
vets on the agri-food sector after the
grace period has ended and will explain
to the Ulster Farmers Union High by that
list has not been given to them and
would he agree to meet with me in the
Ulster Farmers Union go through that
list and show us how this has removed
the Border in the RAC
well Mr Mr Speaker as as uh The
Honorable gentleman knows uh when we
when we concluded the Windsor framework
uh what we did was make sure that there
was an extension in the grace period for
veterinary medicines to give us the time
to find a long run a solution to that uh
to that particular issue but the
honorable gentleman should take heart
because on the issue of human medicines
which I know is important to him and
everyone else in Northern Ireland what
we did achieve was complete and full
dual regulation of medicines and a
dialogue with the EU to to to
um to resolve the issues in Veterinary
medicines and I know that he will want
to make sure that we engage closely with
him and the ufu which we have been doing
to find a resolution in the time we have
but I know he will also join me in being
very happy that we protected access to
human medicines in Northern Ireland
which was a priority for him and his
party
I really look forward to welcoming the
prime minister to Portman Road for
Ipswich Town Southampton next season of
course in addition to Ipswich town it's
just Wanderers have always been have
also been promoting great news for a
town yesterday though we saw despite the
public order at being passed we saw
images of Metropolitan Police standing
around and doing nothing whilst Eco
protesters were wrecking havoc in our
Capital does the Prime Minister agree
with us at the moment that his activists
stand on the road they should be
immediately turfed off the road like
there are in many other countries
[Music]
all right Mr Speaker on uh on honorable
friends uh first observation all I can
say is ouch but thank you but I look
forward to the game um Madonna's second
most amount of matter uh this government
has passed a serious disruption order uh
which will ensure that police do have
the powers that they need to tackle
slow-moving protests it was a power that
the police specifically asked the
government for we've delivered it and
put it in legislation he knows what I
know is that the party opposite tried to
block that from happening
thank you Mr Speaker prime minister we
have four million children living in
poverty in this country yet we are the
fifth richest economy in the world so
can the Prime Minister say why he would
not support Universal free School meals
for all children to end child poverty
Mr Mr Speaker the the numbers are
actually as follows since 2010 there are
1.7 million fewer people living in
poverty as a result of the actions of
this government and that includes
hundreds of thousands fewer children
living in poverty and most importantly
because like the honorable lady I do
want to ensure that children don't grow
up in poverty but we know that the best
way to do that is to ensure that they
don't grow up in a workless household
and that's why that's why we have
reduced the number of children growing
up in a workless household by several
thousand and that is the most powerful
thing we can do in the long run to give
those children the best possible to
start in life
Mr Speaker Nancy Spencer from Darlington
has raised over 35
000 pounds for Saint Teresa's Hospice in
the last 25 years
Nazi's next adventure was to do a
Skydive but having had a pacemaker
fitted her doctor refused to sign it off
however undeterred my 80 year old
constituent managed to secure a sign off
for a wing walk will my right honorable
friend join me in Wishing Nancy well as
she takes to the skies this Saturday
[Applause]
well can I uh can I join my honorable
friend in thanking Nancy for all her
fantastic fundraising work and of course
wish her the best of luck for Saturday I
do wonder if my honorable friend will be
joining her
um but and in particular many of my many
of my own constituents use centuries
hospice uh over the years so I know what
fabulous work it does but more generally
the hospice sector supports more than
300 000 people with life limiting
conditions in the UK every year and I
pay tribute to all the staff and
volunteers working in palliative and
end-of-life care for the incredible work
they do Mr Speaker does the Prime
Minister agree that it's completely
inappropriate for schools to encourage
young people under the age of 18 to
socially transition for example by
changing their names and their pronouns
all this is going on without parental
consent or even knowledge in breach of
parents human rights will the Prime
Minister instruct the Department of
Education to order schools to stop
indoctrinating our children and to
concentrate on their duty of care to
protect them oh Mr Mr Speaker I've been
very clear that when it comes to matters
of sexual education and phsc it is
absolutely right that schools are
sensitive in how they teach those
matters they should be done in an
age-appropriate fashion the department
for education is currently reviewing the
sanctuary guidance and curriculum that
goes to school so we can tackle this
particular issue because there have been
uh cases raised with the government and
others where this has not been with has
not been the case I don't think that's
acceptable we must protect our children
and that's what our new guidance will do
thank you Mr Speaker last year the
independent members of The Betsy
kidwallada Health Board in North Wales
became so concerned about the board's
finances that they arranged for Ernst
young to produce a forensic accountancy
report which revealed serious misconduct
on the part of several senior board
Executives including a conspiracy to
fortify accounts astonishingly the
response of the labor Welsh Health
secretary to this Scandal was to demand
the resignation of those independent
board members while almost all the
senior Executives in question have been
allowed to remain in post many of them
drawing six-figure salaries does the
Prime Minister agree that this
disgraceful State of Affairs should be
investigated by the police and does he
further agree that it demonstrates why
labor are unfit to run important Public
Services
[Applause]
speakers my runnable friend knows I am
deeply worried about the Betsy kudwalder
Hospital in labor run North Wales it has
been as he said in special measures for
six of the last eight years and as he
remarked the official audit said there
was worrying dysfunctionality I do hope
this issue is investigated properly and
I believe my honorable friend is in
contact with the Secretary of State for
Wales to take this further oh no Mr
Speaker working people a bard
from receiving legal aid if they earn 12
750 pounds a year
so why is the prime minister
forcing the British public to foot the
bill which I think is currently 250 000
pounds plus
for the right honorable member for
Oxbridge and South Rush trips alleged
lagging inquiry
why can't he stand up for the British
people is it because he's too weak
uh Mr Mr Speaker it's it's actually a
long established process across multiple
administrations that former ministers
aren't supported with legal
representation after they have left
office to deal with matters that relate
to their time in office that has been
the practice for many years as I said
across multiple political
administrations both labor and
conservatives no question Dean Russell
thank you Mr Speaker
um I uh yeah thank you I welcome the
government's ongoing engagements to
ensure that mental health is treated as
equally as physical health and of course
in my own constituency of Watford
Watford General Hospital we've recently
received about 350 000 pounds for
improvements to mental health facilities
which will help massively but given the
importance of this issue with the Prime
Minister join me in encourage
encouraging fellow colleagues from
across the house to attend an event I'll
be hosting for the Baton of Hope on the
Terrace Pavilion at pmq after pmqs today
to raise awareness around mental health
and suicide prevention thank you
well Mr Speaker honorable friend is a
fantastic campaigner on mental health
and I'm pleased to learn about all the
work he is doing with the Baton of hope
I'm pleased that we're also putting more
government money into Mental Health
Services and taking more action on this
issue than any previous government
investing an extra 2.3 billion pounds a
year and I would encourage all
colleagues to join him in attending the
reception on the terrorist Pavilion that
complete prime minister's questions
and there you go the end of prime
minister's questions
um
Rishi sunak just over an hour after he
confirmed that his Home Secretary will
not be investigated for asking officials